[Music]
describe the endless summer tour in
three words I am so ready for the
endless summer tour I'm ready to dance
I'm ready to party
explain what is in store for us it's a
really eclectic experience you know from
all the artists that are on there and
you know everybody's given a different
sound a different perspective a
different energy and it's a really dope
to see something like this come together
that's right you've collaborated with so
many incredible artists throughout the
years can we expect anybody on stage the
Sun absolutely
I think for the fans that's like that's
a special part of the experience is when
they you know they get that surprise you
know like somebody gets brought out that
they weren't expecting do you ever get
nervous taking the stage or knowing
certain people are in the audience
absolutely that my bread the VMAs when I
got to his and I was like one of the
craziest experiences of my life
and I remember walking out on stage and
I looked up and yeah it was just like
right there front and center yeah big
that's yes
I've already got music on lock you're
now in the liquor business yeah what's
left I would love to go an ad is there
someone that you really admire their
kind of inspired yeah we know capita
oh really he's just the cleanest cat to
ever live oh my god have you met it yeah
it was crazy we're at an Oscar party and
I was luckily I was like tipsy enough to
not be so nervous yeah and I just I saw
him walk past me on the wall and I just
tapped him and I talked to him and um
and he was like Kelly you're dope kid
you're a rock star like I like you and I
was like I think I fainted
oh my gosh you know he's playing your
music this place is crazy because if I
you forget that everybody's a human
being mutual fans of each other I was
really crazy they enjoy music just like
we did
[Music]
[Applause]